hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
and welcome back to my channel in
today's video I'm going to talk about
you know another tool set in the
orderflows trader 7 software called the
POC wave and the PC wave is a three bar
setup looking at the Port of controls
over those three bars and how they um
appear in those three bars in relation
to each other now before I jump in again
if you enjoy my videos be sure to uh hit
the like button and subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already you know
you sport really does go long way in
helping me uh create more content for
this Channel all right so the PLC wave
you know I first uh I wrote about the
PLC wave years ago I think around 20 I
had it in a course in 20
um I think it was
2017 or no 2018 um when I created the
orderflows uh point of control trading
course and actually I had this years ago
I thought I was going to uh program my
stuff for Sierra charts I had some guy
programmed this for me on Sierra charts
so you know it's sort of been on the
back burner and I I wrote about it but I
never bothered with it for Ninja Trader
for some reason because I I thought you
know it should be very visual for people
to see and then uh just over the past
year people have been telling me yeah
you know the PC wave I I use it um you
know in this market and on this type of
chart and it works
fantastic so you know I said hey you
know I should put it in I should
actually have it in my software um
that's why we we've added it in in the
latest version of the order flows Trader
software so let me just uh add it onto
to the Chart here okay so you're going
to go on to your footprint chart your
orderflow Trader footprint chart go to
the indicator settings find POC wave
here okay so you can enable it and you
can enable the swing filter but I won't
do that for now the draw mode I'll keep
it fixed I I'll show you what it looks
like first um it's going to be bullish
waves are BL blue bearish waves are
going to be red color the opacity is set
at 20 might be a little bit hard to see
on this but I I'll make it a little bit
stronger here um just for this uh video
here I just make it 70 but you could
keep it at 20 okay so let's just go back
here and take a look here so see this
red box here this is a bearish POC wave
okay it's a three bar setup right you
got green bar Red Bar red bar so green
bar point of control comes in someplace
then next bar is a red bar with a higher
point of control third bar is a red bar
with a lower point of control from the
initial bar so bar one bar two bar three
bar one is the green candle Bar for a
bearish setup is going to start green
and then go red
red Market's going to trade higher put a
little volume above the previous high
volume area then Market is going to
start to go down and it's going to um
put in a lower point of control okay now
let's see where's the bullish one here's
a bullish one so it starts off a bullish
one is a red candle with a green bar and
then third bar is green candle point of
control in the first bar okay that's
like your starting point second bar
comes in the lower point of control and
it's a green candle third bar is a green
candle with a higher point of control
than the first bar so point of control
one two is lower three is higher than
the first one okay so second bars point
of control is
lower than the first one the third point
of control is higher than the first
point of control okay now you notice
what we do we put a box around here okay
there's couple things we color one we we
put a box around the entire three bars
okay and then at the low the second bar
it's
low if it's a bullish one we have this
Zone drawn out here that say this
Blue Area
okay for a bearish one right it's red
color box how do I know it's a bearish
ones cuz I know it starts out green
followed by two red bars just as a
bullish one I know it's going to be
bullish it starts out red followed by
two green
bars got the box around the bearish one
you got that little Zone drawn out there
the way you trade this okay
and there's two things keep in mind
the way you trade it
one the the low of this box right the
Box around the three bars that's where
you're going to be getting short from
this line up here this red line that's
your stop price just as here the area
you're going to get long from is the top
of
this blue
box so right here 21
85.3 that's where you want to be long
from your stop 84 Point well right below
this so 84 2184 just as here your sh are
you want to get short is 84.6 with a
stop just above this at 21
86.6
okay you're this is where you get short
this is where you get short this is
where you Trail your stop this is where
your Trail your stop
okay now
people say well wouldn't you want to
Trail your stuff from the top of the box
well I mean you could but really what we
find is when you
have the PLC wave and it's going to hold
it won't go back above the second bars
high or low okay
now what you can do again put it in
context right and this is where it
becomes really powerful cuz look okay
I'll be honest right here's a PC wave PC
wave PLC wave PLC wave all right PLC
wave this one obviously failed even
though it's 2:00 in the afternoon um
people say well you know there was one
here it didn't work out well yeah okay
you wouldn't be taking this trade
because it didn't go below here but what
I always say where is the best trading
opportunities going to come from it's
going to come from swing highs or swing
lows okay good buying opportunities come
off of lows good selling opportunities
come off of highs all right
so you know cuz there'll be people say
oh you know I took this trade here and
it went up a tick two ticks three ticks
and it stopped me out okay well really
probably should have been long from much
lower here at 82 instead of getting long
at 84.6 or even down
here so by using the swing
filter okay where are we here PC
wave enable swing filter again it's
linked to this swing period right here
click
apply click okay now it's going to only
show
me the bullish and bearish signals
coming in at swing lows or swing
highs okay so this one okay this one
again you wouldn't have gotten long
because it didn't break out above the
top of this box
you see there was that one that was
there the bearish one's not showing up
so you can see it cleans it up a lot
right and it's giving you my opinion
much higher percentage trades that have
you know more capacity to run you know
from a swing High here you know we're
talking 78 2178 not to
75 there again move from
75 if that that doesn't even come it
comes close to stopping you out gets
down to 71 before it goes all the way
back up to
80 it's a nice move
here from you know what is at
87 down into the
70s this one well you wouldn't have
gotten short because it didn't go below
this the low of the box here
um you know that's gold you know I don't
know crude
oil excuse me sorry for that I'm just
getting over this really
bad influenza it's not
Co but uh think I I want say thank God
it's not Co but honestly you
know anytime you get a cough everyone
you got
Co um you know here's a nice there's one
I say nice one here's one okay you can
see the high of this bar or the high of
the Box rather is at$
77.93 okay
which doesn't get traded through for 1 2
3 4 5 6 minutes okay now granted it's 2
o'clock in the afternoon on Friday
um would you take that trade probably
not because it's 2:00 on Friday but this
one here at 1:00 108 high of the box
7773 or 7 72 rather but 73 is where you
get long from 73 all the way up above uh
bucks here's one again it just struggled
you know okay that one probably stopped
you out it's a bullish one here is a
bearish one
here here's a nice little move here
here's a nice move here but really on
Friday if you
remember the the big move in crude came
uh came overnight it's really really
hard to see on a Time based
chart but uh let's put this on a range
based
chart
okay see see here's a short to a long to
a
short short
here some shorts back you little bit of
back and forth It's the thing when
you're trading a range based chart right
you
get sometimes you get these quick trades
what I call Quick trades um especially
when the market is volatile CU it'll go
up three or four bars come off three or
four bars back up three or four
bars right here there
you know just is what I'm talking about
being being being and some Traders like
that right because they're they're in
and out scalping um back and forth it
really just depends on your style of
trading right look at this move from
overnight right the nice bearish wave
coming in around 7980 right the low is
84 if you're getting short around
80 even say 75 7975 it breaks all the
way down to the bullish one down here at
7865 so it's over $1
move so again that's the PC wave it it's
again it's a nice tool to use by itself
it's a nice tool you could use to
complement with other forms of order
flow
analysis where is it here P wave here so
again you know see how it will work on
your Trading
you know whether you want to use it uh
with the swing filter or not is up to
you all right everyone take care see you
guys on the next video